للمزيد ينظر الينا مراسات في موسكو مازن
عباس اهلا بك مازن على اي اساس ترتكز
الوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه في هذه
الاتهامات
عفوا لندن واشنطن والاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
التابعه لهما في هذا في شن هذه الضربه
يعني
بحسب اراء الخبراء الروس الذين تحدثوا في
وقت سابق عن مريض خاربه يرون اولا ان هذا
الهجوم الذي نفذ على ميناء سبا انما جاء
عبر تسلسل لضربات من مختلف الوسائل
والاتجاهات وجاء ضمن اطار زمني ومكاني
دقيق الامر الذي يتطلب بالتاكيد بيانات
استخباراتيه دقيقه يمكن توفير هذه
البيانات عبر طائرات استكشاف واخبار
صناعيه واجهزه توجيه رادار بعيده المدى
وهذه الامكانيات لا تتوفر الا لدى
الولايات المتحده او بريطانيا بحسب موسكو
بالتاكيد وبالتالي ان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا قد شاركتها في تخطيط لهذه لهذا
الهجوم
وتنفيذ ايضا الهجوم باعتبار انهما قامت
بتوفير كافه البيانات اللازمه لهذا التحرك
العسكري بناء عليه هناك اتهام صريح موجه
للولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بالمشاركه في
هذا
على ميناء هذا ما يتعلق بالميناء وبشكل
عام معروف ان هناك اتهام روسي لي كل من
واشنطن بانهما تقومان بتوفير امدادات من
الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا لضرب
روسيا واضعافها وبالتالي
تفتيت روسيا الى ماده تؤثر هكذا ضربات على
على روسيا تتحدث اليوم السلطات عن
تعليق حركه السيارات على جثه القرم لاي
مدى هكذا ضربات تؤثر على روسيا لا شك ان
هذه الضربه كانت ضربه نوعيه بحسب تقديرات
الخبراء العسكريين الروس باعتبار انه
استخدمت في عمليات قصف صاروخي بالاضافه
للمسيرات
وقسمتها ايضا وبالتالي هذه الضربات هي
تصيب العمق وقد سببت بالفعل اضرار بحسب
اعتراف وزاره الدفاع الهجوم الذي سبق
الهجوم الاخير على ميناء سباستوبل تسبب في
تدمير مبنى واندلاع الحرائق فيه واصابه
حوض جاف وسفينتين بل واصابتها وجرح عدد
كبير من العام عسكريين في هذه المنطقه هذا
الهجوم
التصريحات الرسميه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تسبب في تدمير اجزاء كبيره من مقر قياده
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي وفقدان جندي
واحد فقط بالتاكيد هذه الضربات هي اكثر
تاثيرا من الضربات التي كانت توجهها
القوات الاوكرانيه عبر المسيرات والتي
عمليا لم تكن تحقق اهدافها بحسب بيانات
وزاره الدفاع الروسي شكرا جزيلا
لكاس في موسكو